sénateur avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur c'est un avis défavorable
monsieur le Président même avis donc je
mets au voix
l'amendement 539 rectifier bis qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas
adopté article 9 amendement 3 315
rectifié monsieur bénaroche alors chers
collègues juste un petit instant si vous
si on peut les uns et les autres être
concis de façon à avoir
achevé rapidement dans quelques dans le
jours qui viennent demain l'examen de ce
texte ce serait pas mal alors je vous
invite les uns et les autres à la
concision si vous le pouvez et si vous
le désirez je vous en prie Monsieur
bénaroche Je je remercie beaucoup le
président de faire cette remarque juste
avant ma prise de parole moi qui suis
toujours très aussi tout à fait je vous
en prie merci monsieur le Président
néanmoins je je me permets de revenir un
peu de sérieux puisque cet article
article 9 nous paraît être l'un des
articles les plus dangereux et les plus
difficiles à accepter de ce projet de
loi l'article 9 en fait c'est des
dispositions qui marquent le retour en
force de la double peine pour l'ensemble
des étranger qui auraiit commis une
infraction la présente mesure prévoit de
fragil la catégorie des étrangers
bénéficiant de la protection dite quasi
absolue cette protection concerne
notamment des personnes résidant en
France depuis quelles ont au moins
depuis qu'elles ont moins de 13 ans
ou résidant de manière régulière depuis
plus de 20 ans ou encore les étrangers
malades la mesure qui nous est proposée
prévoit d'abolir les protections non
plus en raison de la peine
prononcée mais de la peine encouru il
s'agit d'un assoublissement
excessivement large et beaucoup trop
large englobant même des délit de faible
gravité en effet loin de viser quelques
centaines d'étrangers condamnés pour un
crime il y en a eu 451 en 2021 ces
dispositions concernent près de 99 % des
étrangers condamnés qu'il le sont pour
des délits cet assoublissement soulève
donc la question de la la conformité de
ce dispositif aux obligations
internationales de la France le critère
de la peine encourue de délit Passi
d'une peine de 5 ans en lieu et place de
peine prononcé et disproportionné au
regard des conséquences qu'une décision
d'expulsion aura sur ses droits
fondamentaux et sur les personnes qui en
font l'objet et les membres de leur
famille je merci monsieur le sénateur
madame à monsieur le
rapporteur c'est vous qui prenez la
parole pour
donner l'avis de la
commission excusez-moi défavorable mais
j'ai pensais le prendre sur l'ensemble
des amendement de ce pardon défavorable
je pensais le prendre sur non il n'est
pas en discussion commune donc il faut
que vous donniez votre avis sur cet
amendement défavorable monsieur le
ministre oui quelques mots très rapides
monsieur le Président juste à la fois
pour répondre à Monsieur benaroch et la
question de la constitutionnalité ou de
la conventionnalité de la mesure et de
manière générale sur ce que l'on veut
faire dans le 9 10 puis 13 mais d'abord
le 9 le 9
c'est l'arrêté ministériel d'expulsion
donc qui concerne expulsion d'étranger
irrégulier irrégulier donc c'est un
arrêté que peut prendre le préfet et
plus souvent le ministre de l'Intérieur
il y a très peu de mesures par an moins
d'un millier on veut évidemment
l'étendre vous avez compris j'ai compris
que vous n'étiez pas d'accord sur ce
point en levant les protections qui
empêchent le minist d'intérieur de
prendre ces arrêtés ministériels
d'expulsion qui certes permettent une
expulsion plus rapide mais donne aussi
des garanties plus fortes à la personne
que l'on veut expulser notamment une
commission de magistrat et cetera et
cetera je veux dire à Monsieur benaroche
pour répondre parfaitement à sa question
que il n'y a pas et le Conseil d'État
d'ailleurs l'a dit dans son avis il n'y
a pas
de de texte dans notre bloc de
constitutionnalité ou dans la cdH qui
empêche de revenir sur les protections
qui avaient été décidé par le
législateur sur proposition d'ailleurs
du ministre Sarkozi en 2003 nous sommes
le seul pays à avoir mis ces protections
là dans toute l'Union européenne et donc
que c'est vraiment du pur droit
législatif alors évidemment il y a une
disposition surquelle nous proposons pas
de revenir d'ailleurs personne ici à
l'auel des amendements ce sont les
mineurs qui commettent des actes graves
pendant qu'ils sont mineurs mais ça on
est d'accord c'est la Convention
européenne des Droits de l'enfant
notamment que nous avons signé mais
toutes les autres sont levés alors on
verra qu'il y a plusieurs types de
rédaction possibles et ça ne veut pas
dire monsieur benaroche et là peut-être
arrive le débat constitutionnel bien sûr
ou d'autres débats qui vous concernent
qu'il n'y a pas de juge pour regarder ce
que nous faisons de prenant arrêté
ministériel d'expulsion et après le juge
constate si la vie privée est familiale
l'emporte sur le trouble grave à l'ordre
public ou si le trouble l'emporte sur la
vie privée et familiale pour la nation
c'est le même principe qu'on a qu'on a
mis en place pour l'intérêt fondamental
de la Nation pour ce qui touche le
terrorisme donc il y a évidemment pardon
de dire comme ça discussion chez le chez
le juge bien sûr mais aujourd'hui le
discussion chez le juge n'est même pas
possible pour le ministre de l'Intérieur
les protections fait que si quelqu'un
est dans le cadre des éction voté par le
législateur il y a 25 ans je ne peux
même pas prendre d'arrêter Minister
d'expulsion et donc je ne peux même pas
aller devant le juge donc un c'est
l'expulsion on verra après qu'el
éloignement de ce n'est c'est
constitutionnel et conventionnel 3 il a
évidemment un équilibre mais le ministre
d'intérieur doit faire son travail de
ministre à l'intérieur et le juge fera
son travail de juge déforable merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur
Baroche monsieur le ministre bien
entendu s'il y a
protection c'est que à un moment donné
nous avons jugé le législateur a jugé le
ministre de l'époque a jugé qu'il
fallait protéger et nous ce que nous
disons avec le défenseur de droit
d'ailleurs c'est qu'en fait c'est le
curseur que vous déplacez et que le
déplacement de ce curseur est
particulièrement inquiétant non
seulement car la référence à la peine en
couru plutôt que prononcer va à l'encre
du principe d'individualisation de la
peine mais également car dans les faits
les peines encourues sont très
supérieures aux peines prononcées si
bien que la levée il nous l' ça nous
vous a été expliqué hier par Monsieur
spitler car dans les
fait si si bien que la levée des
protections contre l'expulsion
concernera de fait un champ beaucoup
plus large et très très large de
personnes pour lesquelles la gravité de
la menace représenté sera loin d'être
établi c'est là où nous bougeons le
curseur et c'est le fait de le bouger
qui nous paraît préoccupant le risque d'
tête sera d'autant plus important que le
recours contre l'expulsion n'est pas en
principe
suspensif par ailleurs en visant les
parents d'enfants français et les
personnes mariées avec des conjoints
français les dispositions de l'article 9
génèent aussi un déséquilibre entre
l'objectif de sauvegarde de l'ordre
public par des mesures de police
administrativ et les exigences du droit
de mener une vie humaine familial
protégé par l'article 8 de la Convention
européenne de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
ainsi que par les articles 3 et 9 de la
CIDE pour l'ensemble de ces raisons
monsieur le ministre je réitère que
notre groupe demande la préci de cet
article merci Monsieur le
Ministre avec une notion de la rapidité
qui nous RA j'espère vousi pas aller
débat mais c'est vraiment un article
très important qui sera d'ailleurs
scruté par le Conseil constitutionnel
donc je veux vraiment le redire ici
après on ira peut-être un peu plus vite
dans les amendements mais pour dire à
Monsieur benroch que son explication et
je comprends sa position évidemment elle
est elle est respectable bien évidemment
elle est pas celle du gouvernement qui a
besoin évidemment d'élargir les champs
parce que vous avez tout à fait compris
la mesure monsieur le sénateur c'est
effectivement d'ouvrir la possibilité de
plus de personnes qui mériteraient euh
l'expulsion du point de vue du ministère
de de l'Intérieur euh aujourd'hui il
pour faire très vite expulsion
éloignement il y a 2500 étrangers
délinquants que je je j'arrive à faire
expulser
euh in concretto et 4000 euh par an à
peu près c'est à peu près toujours le le
même le même sujet que je n'arrive pas à
expulser non pas parce que j'ai pas les
laissé passer consulaires non pas parce
que le juge m'empêche de le faire mais
parce que ils font partie de ces
réserves d'ailleurs euh nous avons si
vous le souhaitez pour ceux que ça
intéresse tout un tas d'exemples
extrêmement préoccupants par exemple un
un ressortissant d'un pays je vais pas
le citer entré en France en décembre
2001 à l'âg 8 ans l'intéressé n'est pas
marié n'a pas d'enfant sur le territoire
national et ne présente aucun
justificatif d'insertion professionnelle
il ne justifie d'aucun tytre de séjour
il présente 12 condamnations je parle
pas d'accusation de la part de la police
he 12 condamnation au casier en 9 ans
dans la dernière avec 18 mois de prison
ferme conduite sans permis avec récidif
usage de stupéfiant vol aggravé en
récidive il est entré en France avant
l'âge de 13 ans il n donc pas possible
de l'ineexpulsé le même ressortissant
d'un pays différent avec à peu près le
même le même profil à part que lui il a
été condamné seulement à Sep
condamnation comme il est arrivé à l'âge
de 13 ans et demi je peux l'expulser
voilà je pense qu'il y a aucune
cohérence à à tout cela cette personne
n'a pas de lien avec notre pays il n'a
pas d'enfant il n'est pas marié il n'a
pas d'ation professionnelle com même il
en aurait d'ailleurs on pourrait quand
même proposer l'expulsion mais sous
prétexte qui est arrivé avant l'âge de
13 ans je ne peux pas procéder à son
expulsion en tout cas je ne peux même
pas aller devant le juge alors qu'il n'a
pas de lien avec notre pays bon voilà et
il commettent en général c mfit un peu
plus après 18 ans le fait d'être resté
quelques années sur notre territoire ne
ne justifie pas de pouvoir garder des
des des personnes qui mettent des crimes
de façon
récidiv merci monsieur le ministre je
vais mettre voix donc l'amendement 315
rectifié avec un double avis euh
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 348 rectifié par
Monsieur le Président
retaill bien l'article 9 l'article 10
sont très importants ça vient d'être dit
dans dans le débat qui qui a commencé le
13 octobre nos compatriotes les Français
ont été doublement sidérés une première
fois sidérés parce qu'ils ont appris à
nouveau qu'un professeur de la
République venait d'être assassiné une
seconde fois sidéré lorsque ils ont
appris que cet
individu aurait pu faire l'objet
d'expulsion mais qui n'a pas été expulsé
pourquoi parce qu'il était arrivé sur le
territoire français avant l'âge de 13
ans et les
Français totalement sidérés ont vu que
nous avions une règle l'expulsion pour
des individus dangereux étrangers mais
que cette règle était tellement trouée
qu'elle avait été en quelque sorte tuée
par les exceptions les exceptions on tué
la règle et ces exceptions menacent
désormais les Français
progressivement nous avons abandonné les
instruments juridiques de régulation de
l'immigration progressivement nous avons
organisé parfois nous-mêm comme vient de
le dire le ministre il y a quelques
instants notre propre impuissance
comment voulez-vous que les Français
comprennent que ce sont des individus
étrangers très dangereux qui parfois ont
été condamnés très clirement y compris
par des crimes de sang pour des crimes
de sang comment voulez-vous que les
Français nos compatriotes comprennent
que on protège ces individus et qu'on
laisse exposer à leur menaces à leur
violence à leur barbarie les Français
honnêtes paisiblebles je sais qu' va
mêre tout à l'heure opposé
l'inconstitutionnalité
l'inconventionnalité chers collègues
nous sommes des législateurs nous sommes
là pour exprimer la volonté générale et
je pense que ce débat doit avoir lieu
mon amendement ne concerne pas les
mineurs de moins 18 ans mon amendement
ne surtranspose pas et devons pas
surtransposer les règles de la CEDH
c'est au juges pour l'ITF ou à
l'administration pour l'arrêté
d'expulsion de mettre le curseur sous le
regard bien sur des tribunaux sous le
regard des tribunaux mais de grâce ne
surtransposition pas et et donnons aux
Français le gage d'une vraie
protection merci monsieur le Président
avis avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur oui l'avis de la
commission monsieur le Président sera un
avis de
sagesse vous y voyez immédiatement
l'attention le témoignage de l'attention
qui est porté à la fois votre amendement
monsieur retillot mais au-delà de de
votre
avendement à votre expression et à
l'ampleur du sujet pour nos concitoyens
nos concitoyens bien sûr été sidérés par
les drames auxquels vous avez fait
référence ils ont été sidérés de de
comprendre ou de mesurer les
conséquences de ces protections monsieur
le ministre en a parlé dans son propos
introductif lundi la levée des
protections absolues et relatives et le
sujet qui est en dép il y a deux
manières d'aborder ce
sujet et je vais vous présenter monsieur
le Président finalement les différents
amendements une première manière qui
consiste à dire enlève toutes les
protections il n'y a plus aucune
protection ou de
dire on lève les protections dans toute
une série de situations et de mesurer
ensemble si le champ des possible répond
à la préoccupation de nos concitoyens et
à la préoccupation que vous avez exprimé
monsieur reetaillot et donc je vais
aller directement à la conclusion après
je vais essayer de vous la
justifier effectivement la question que
vous posez est une anticipation du débat
que vous avez prévu ça fera de ma part
le 13 décembre le sujet constitutionnel
dont on comprend parfaitement la la
teneur et dont vous nous avez fixé
quelque part le le cadre le cadre
intellectuel et parallèlement jeose plus
dire en même temps nous allons essayer
de regarder ensemble tout ce qui peut
être fait et chers collègues vous allez
être étonné par l'ampleur non seulement
de ce qui peut être fait mais de ce que
vous avez prévu les et les autres dans
vos amendements parce que entre les
amendements rapporteurs l'amendement de
Monsieur carucci l'amendement de
madameidman l'amendement du
Gouvernement je pense que le tour des
possible est réellement considérable et
va répondre me semblet-il de manière
assez saaisante aux préoccupations vous
avez exprimé monsieur reillot encore une
fois pas à titre personnel mais au nom
de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens alors
pourquoi nous ne pouvons nous avons une
difficulté sur la levée sur la
suppression sèche
des des protection c'est pas un sujet
conventionnel pour une fois c'est
vraiment un sujet purement
constitutionnel tout simplement parce
que le Conseil constitutionnel nous
impose alors je cite une décision de
2005 d'assurer une conciliation
équilibrée entre la sauvegarde de
l'ordre public et le droit de mener une
vie familiale normale
nous sommes là dans ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel tire du 10e alignéat du
Préambule de la Constitution de 1946 qui
vous savez tout a été intégré dans bloc
de constitutionnalité et dans ce cadre
effectivement le Conseil constitutionnel
estime qu'il a un droit à la vie privée
familiale sur ce point et je ne serai
pas plus long il y a comme souvent en
matière
constitutionnelle une conciliation
équilibrée une tension à mettre en place
entre deux principes vous n'allez pas
être surpris chers collègues c'est quand
même sont des sujets classiques pour
chacun d'entre vous la protection de
l'ordre public la sauvegarde de l'ordre
public et de l'autre côté la protection
de la vie privée familiale le
législateur peut très bien dans cet
exercice de curseur mettre l'accent sur
la sauvegarde de l'ordre public et vous
en avez la possibilité là où on sait par
avance que le Conseil constitutionnel va
nous répondre non c'est que ça ne peut
pas être un 100 % en ordre public et un
0 % vie privée familiale ce qui serait
le cas si on supprimait complètement les
protections qu'elle soit absolue et
relative si maintenant on regarde tout
ce que l'on peut faire vous allez avoir
les amendements rapporteur qui prévoit
premièrement une baisse
des seuils pour la levée nous
passons à nous proposons de passer à 5
ans pour les protections absolues et 3
ans pour les protections relatives pour
répondre à Monsieur benénaroche il est
exact que dans ce cadre nous souhaitons
abaisser fortement le niveau et 5 ans
c'est un vol avec une circonstance
aggravante 3 ans un vol simple donc ces
deux exemples vous montrent qu'on
descend bas le niveau de protection nous
ne pensons pas qu'on permettre d'aller
au-delà puisque immédiatement on va
avoir les problèmes constitutionnels et
je ne vous cache pas qu'en vous
proposant cela nous testons nous-même
les limites de la des positions du
Conseil constitutionnel qui n'ont pas eu
sur le principe je vous l'ai présenter
sur le niveau ça on ne peut pas donner
d'éléments puisque cette législation sur
les prot faudra conclure allez-y allez-y
alors je termine je vais avec les ce que
l'on peut vous proposer vous avez un
amendement sur l'abaissement des seuils
de permettant la convention 5 ans et 3
ans vous avez ensuite les violences
intra familial que nous introduisons
avec avec en plus les violences sur les
ascendants nous vous introduisons nous
vous proposons de prononcer
unitf la possibilité pour les jeux
prononcer unitf
à partir de 3 ans d'emprisonnement nous
vous présent nous vous proposerons un
avis favorable sur l'amendement de
monsieur carucci qui écarte toute
protection absolue ou relative lorsque
l'étranger est en situation
irrégulière nous vous proposerons un
avantvis favorable sur le 583 de madame
esliman qui supprime toute protection en
cas de violence sur les élus et les
agents publics et nous vous proposerons
un amendement favorable sur le 611 du
gouvernement qui supprime également
toutes les protections en cas d'atteinte
aux valeurs de la République il nous
semble que dans l'ensemble des possibles
que nous ouvrons nous apportons une une
solution non pas 100 % mais très
largement dans le sens de ce que le
président retaillot a exprimé me
semble-t-il au nom d'une très large
partie de nos concitoyens j'attire enfin
votre attention sur un dernier un
dernier élément sans vouloir de près ou
de loin anticiper sur votre votre vote
si vous adoptez l'amendement du
président retaillot par conséquent nous
faisons tomber tous les amendements
subséquents imaginons que la force de
conviction du président retaillot la
force de conviction qu'il exprime et que
peuvent exprimer d'autres conduisent
avoir ceci dans le texte qui sera issu
des débats devant l'ensemble du
Parlement j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel je vais être prudent je
vais dire est probable et que nous
n'avons plus rien derrière c'est-à-dire
que l'ensemble des possibles que je vous
ai défini nous ne l'aurons nous ne
l'aurons plus dans le texte nous
l'aurons perdu nous ne pouvons pas le
sauvegarder je vous demande pas
excusez-moi je vous demande simplement
d'avoir ceci à votre esprit euh au
moment euh où vous prendz chers
collègues la décision merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur nous avons
compris que vous aviez déjà vous êtes
exprimé déjà sur des amendements à venir
voilà donc vous nous dispenserez de de
de longs propos explicatifs ensuite sur
les amendements à venir monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
peut-être rien que la mesure proposée
par le gouvernement qu'elle soit ou pas
modifiée par les quelques amendements de
des rapporteurs c'est jusqu'à 4000
mesures aujourd'hui par an alors qu'on
est plutôt autour de 400 500 aujourd'hui
par an donc la disposition
indépendamment de votre amendement
monsieur le Président c'est déjà une
grosse une très grosse disposition
évidemment je rappelle que l'arrivée
avant l'âge de 13 ans sur le territoire
national c'est 69 % des cas où
l'expulsion n'est pas possible ensuite
vienent la protection des conjoints
français qui Inter en 2è position 22 %
et donc évidemment on voit bien qu'on
est sur le nœ gordien de ce qui nous
arrive sur les étrangers délinquants
donc je voudrais ici dire que l'article
9 prévoit bien des personnes qui ont été
condamné définitivement à de la prison
je pense que pour nos débat c'est
important définitivement à de la prison
et et on avait imaginé dans le texte du
Gouvernement 10 ans ou 5 ans récidif la
commission des lois qu'on va suivre a
évoqué 5 ans voilà je pense que c'est
évidemment déjà important de le dire
c'est des gens qui sont condamnés à plus
de 5 ans de prison ferme de façon
définitive après tout appel donc il
s'agit bien de délinquant ou de criminel
évidemment notoire avec évidemment des
des des difficultés à comprendre pour
les Français moi je rejoins ce que dit
Président rotaillot je prends l'exemple
de deux frères qui sont nés en 91 et un
autre en 95 qui sont nationalité
étrangère qui sont arrivés en France en
2003 qui ont toujours été en situation
régulière l'un a été condamné à 10 ans
d'emprisonnement pour viol sur personnes
vulnérables l'autre a été condamné à 7
ans d'emprisonnement pour proximtisme
aggravé son mineur de moins de 15 ans et
les deux frères bénéficient de la
protection de la loi parce qu'ils sont
arrivés avant l'âge de 13 ans et que
chacun peut se prévaloir de son lien
familiale avec l'autre sur le territoire
national bon là il faut avouer que il y
a un certain nombre de dispositions je
pense que légateur
s'en convaincre qui sont évidemment
absurdes alors monsieur le Président rot
je comprends tout à fait la philosophie
de la présentation de notre amendement
je ne peux y souscrire et je ne peux
donner qu'un avis défavorable non pas
pour vous être désagréable mais parce
que je tiens comm la très bien dit de
rapporteur à l'avancée de ce texte et
notamment qu'au Conseil constitutionnel
on a la valid validité de ce texte parce
que je peux pas ne pas me passer de des
3600 à me supplémentaire que je pourrais
obtenir par l'intermédèire de ce Tex qui
est à mon avis bien plus important que
les autres dispositions qu'on a évoqué
pendant des heures et des heures donc
qu'est-ce qui est constitutionnel et
qu'est-ce qui n'est pas c'est la seule
question qu'on doit se border je
comprends bien que la politique doit
pousser un certain nombre de de cas je
pense que nous le poussons je pense que
ce que nous faisons est constitutionnel
je rappelle d'ailleurs l'avis du Conseil
d'État pour la clarté de nos débats qui
exprcite clairement que le Conseil
d'État considère que le fait d'excepter
des protections l'étranger qui
continuent de menacer gravement l'ordre
public ne Sete à aucun obstacle d'ordre
constitutionnel ou conventionnel dès
lors que les décisions d'explusion sont
soumises au principe de nécessité de
proportionnalité et de l'article 8 de la
CEDH donc nous pensons que notre
dispositif puisque le Conseil d'État l'a
validé il faut le souligner est positif
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça monsieur
le Président rotaot vous allez plus loin
d'ailleurs que la levée des protections
vous le savez bien dans votre amendement
puisque non seulement vous levez toutes
les protection alors que nous les levons
évidemment mais pour ceux qui sont
condamnés à plus de 50 prisons ferme
mais en plus vous mettez des
dispositions de peine automatique pour
les retours les retours la condation
retour donc vous vous engagez le juge à
avoir une peine autom tique ce qui est
clairement vous le savez bien contraire
à la Constitution à la libre
individualisation de de la peine par les
magistrats et par ailleurs vous a
augmenté la les peines encouru de
manière à notre avis disproportionnelle
ce qui peut s'entendre évidemment
politiquement et qui ne peut pas exister
en dehors d'une réforme
constitutionnelle et même celle-ci
d'ailleurs ne permettrait pas une
garantie mais on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler lors de votre proposition de
loi constitutionnelle donc moi j'invite
après avoir eu ce débat vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président à retirer votre
amendement pour le bien pour le bien de
ce texte parce que il est je crois
proportionnel il va assez loin ça ne
veut pas dire que ça épuise des débats
d'ordre constitutionnel ou conventionnel
dans la proposition de loi que vous
faites mais ici nous sommes en train de
faire la loi ordinaire sinon je seraai
donné obligé de donner un avis
défavorable j'aurai l'occasion
d'ailleurs de donner sur d'autres sujets
monsieur le rapporteur à l'exception du
631 de Madame jourdda on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler donc c'est pas un
désaccord de principe c'est juste pour
sauver ce texte très important pour la
sécurité de nos
compatriotes merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à madame
naraassig merci monsieur le Président
alors je crois que le fait que ce ce cet
amendement soit pas soit pas
constitutionnel a déjà été bien établi
il est aussi contraire à la Convention
Européenne des des droits de l'homme
mais je je veux quand même plus plus
globalement aussi sur cet article bien
sûr dire que je crois que nous sommes
tous ici préoccupé par la question de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et que l'État
nous voulons tous nous assurer que
l'État a les moyens d'assurer la sûreté
de l'État et la protection de nos
concitoyens et
concitoyennes vis-à-vis de ces menaces
donc il serait bon que chacun évite les
faux procès et les les amalgames et les
manipulations les instrumentalisations
du de l'attentat
d'aras puisque par ailleurs ce texte a
été rédigé bien avant cet
attentat mais
je voudrais aussi dire que le régime de
l'expulsion tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui il est il comprend déjà il
comprend déjà des mesures qui permettent
de lever les protections dans le cas où
il est avéré que les personnes sont dans
des entreprises terroristes et que donc
la
question ça n'est pas tant de modifier
encore ce droit mais encore une fois des
moyens qu'on veut bien se donner et
peut-être ne pas perdre notre notre
administration nos préfectures euh dans
du suivi notamment sur la question du
travail légal euh et dans la
multiplication on en parlera plus tard
des OQTF euh et que on on puisse
mobiliser plutôt les moyens de l'État
justement sur le suivi de ces individus
véritablement dangereux donc mettons les
moyens là où ils sont nécessaires et
puis rappelons-nous aussi que selon les
chiffres même du ministère de
l'Intérieur la grande majorité des
auteurs d'attentats déjoués ou commis
depuis 2015 sont
français merci madame la sénatrice
madame de non madame de la G ne souhaite
plus s'exprimer
d'accord monsieur le Président
R de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit pour mon
amendement d'effacer les protections les
exceptions à la
règle que dont bénéficie des étrangers
qui ont été condamnés et souvent
lourdement condamné faut toujours lire
les excellents rapports de la commission
des lois je voudrais vraiment remercier
du développement qu'a fait il y a
quelques instants Philippe boncarer même
si nous sommes pas exactement sur la
même longueur d'ond sur l'ensemble de
son développement page 103 je cite un
individu condamné à 42 reprises entre 91
et 2019 pour des faits de vol de trafic
de stupéfiants de violents sur conjoints
de violents sur personnes dépositaires
de l'ordre public outrage et agression
sexuelle est-ce que ça mes chers
collègues c'est faire un amalgame c'est
de cela dont il est les questions c'est
de cela dont nous parlons et on peut pas
noyer ce débat là dans des argu
juridiques moi je suis respectueux avec
l'État de droit et la norme
constitutionnelle mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que souvent il doit y avoir
un équilibre entre l'expression de la
volonté générale la démocratie la
souveraineté populaire et aussi les
décisions juridictionn et rappelez-vous
lorsqu'ici je me souviens avec les
critiques au moment des attentats nous
avions avec notre collègue Philippe B
déplacer le curseur entre la liberté
publique et la sécurité parce qu'il
fallait faire face à des situations
extrêmement dangereuses et Conseil
constitutionnel sauf d'ailleurs la
consultation des sites djihadistes deux
fois Ava été sanctionn incompréhensible
donc ce débat moi je le pose je veux
bien j'ai compris
l'enjeu juridique je veux bien retirer
mon amendement mais je voudrais que le
rapporteur et le ministre me donne
l'assurance que les autres amendements
Roger carucci l'amendement de la
commission marlean et aussi le ministre
pour la commission que vous donniez et
l'un et l'autre et le Gouvernement et la
commission des avis favorables en
d'autres termes je retirerai mon
amendement qu'à la condition de savoir
s' il y a une autre voie de passage
merci président monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous souhaitez donc vous
exprimer après cette interpellation de
du Président rotaillot je vous en prie
oui j'ai je vais peut-être faire la
liste je veux bien m'engager à des
choses sur lesquelles je peux tenir
monsieur le Président rotalo moi je vous
ai déjà dit que je donnerai favorable au
au 631 de Madame Jourda euh pour les
autres je je vais regarder mais je pense
que c'est plutôt j'ai pas encore regardé
su de Monsieur carucci mais il me semble
qu'il n'est pas qu'il n'est pas non plus
constitutionnel des questions en tout
cas je vais regarder tout de suite je
vous le promets si vous me laissez
quelques instants pour que le rapporteur
réponde je veux juste vous dire Monsieur
le Président que je partage éid ce que
vous dites l'exemple que vous avez pris
dans le rapport de la commission des
lois monsieur le Président
rotaot il est répondu avec notre avec le
texte du Gouvernement et le texte de la
commission c'est pas votre c'est pas
votre amendement qui ferait naître
l'expulion de cette personne c'est
l'article 10 tel qu'il est rédigé
aujourd'hui par la commission qui permet
l'expulion de cette personne
entendons-nous bien votre amendement
monsieur le Président rotaillot il
permet pour cette personne d'avoir une
peine automatique par le juge de
nonretour et c'est ça c'est là où
fragiliserait mais vous avez compris
évidemment l'avancée considérable de
l'article 10 donc l'exemple que vous
prenez une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui je
ne pourrai pas l'expulser demain je
pourra l'expulser avec l'article du
gouvernement modifié par la commission
des lois et donc je crois que ça a
atteint le but que nous évoquons je vais
regarder l'amendement de Monsieur caroci
je vais le regarder comme je le fais
toujours avec les sénateurs et
singulièrement avec Monsieur carci avec
un œil particulier
monsieur RET
[Musique]
souhaitez-vous ah le président buffet
monsieur le
Président pour dire au président
rotillot et l'ensemble des collègues que
sur les amendements 630 de Madame la
rapporteur 631 de Madame la rapporteur
583 rectifi B de notre collègueliman 349
rectifi bis de notre collèg carucci et
même 611 du gouvernement les avis sont
favorables
monsieur le Président
rotaillou vous avez bien compris
l'esprit de mon amendement c'est que
notre Parlement sous la 5e République
est terriblement affaibli et si à chaque
fois nous anticipons des décisions du
Conseil constitutionnel en nous
autocensurant on va s'affaiblir encore
plus et on doit porter aussi la
préoccupation de l'intérêt général de la
protection des Français donc si je
comprends bien mon amendement qui
pourrait avoir des difficultés
juridiques si est retiré le sera au
bénéfice d'amendement qui eux
vraisemblement je regarde aussi la
majorité sénatoriale pourrait être voté
c'est dans ces conditionsl que je vais
retirer mon
amendement monsieur le ministre nous
nous prenons je veux pas qu' un marché
entre nous monsieur le Président rotagot
avant de retir votre amendement je ne
peux pas donner un avis favorable à
celui du ministre kuchci
pourquoi c'est l'avis du Conseil d'État
qui me pousse à ne pas le faire l'avis
du Conseil d'État autant il a
oui en fait ça s'appelleétat de droit
monsieur le Président bah oui voilà je
je suis désolé le ministreintérieur a un
Conseil d'État Conseil constitutionnel
c'est vrai je je Maxim cou pas nous
avons porté un article
109 pardon que nous pourrions considérer
à peu près similaire au vôtre dans la
version initiale fournie au Conseil
d'État à l'exception près de la peine
automatique de retour le Conseil d'État
nous a dit à la fois que nous avions
raison possiblement raison que euh nous
pouvions lever les protections c'est ce
que je vous ai dit mais il a dit
attention le Conseil d'État il a dit il
y a deux régime juridique il y a un
régime de l'éloignement et il y a un
régime de l'expulsion le régime de
l'éloignement c'est pour les personnes
dans situation irrégulière avec l'OM de
qtf et qu'on éloigne du territoire
national il y a un régime de l'expulsion
c'est notamment pour les personnes
régulières chacun doit comprendre ici de
ce dont nous parlons c'est des arrêtés
ministériel d'expulsion que nous mettons
à des personnes qui ont des papiers bon
et ce que dit le Conseil d'État c'est
que par le fait de très nombreuses
actions juridiques de jurisprudence mais
aussi de loi on a rapproché les deux
régimes alors que il ne faut pas les
rapprocher c'est le Conseil d'État qui
le dit et c'est un un risque de les
rapprocher parce que il n'apporte pas
les mêmes garanties et que si nous
mettions une ame de façon systématique
en levant toutes les protections aux
personnes en situation irrégulière j'ai
bien compris si j'ai bien compris
l'amendement de Monsieur kucci nous nous
favoriserions l'ame sur le qtf et donc
nous confondions les deux régimes et il
y aurait quelque part une difficulté ou
une inégalité des droits selon la
gravité de la situation et le Conseil
d'État nous a dit le Conseil
constitutionnel considérera sans doute
que l'unification de ces deux régimes ou
le rapprochement de ces deux régimes va
être aggravé par l'amendement de
Monsieur Carocci et donc qui ne sera pas
constitutionnel donc la question c'est
pas d'être contre Monsieur Carocci par
principe c'està dire qu'il y a deux
régimes c'est pour ça qu'il y a deux
articles dans la loi il y a un régime
d'expulsion pour les personnes
régulières et a un régime d'éloignement
pour les personnes irrégulières
l'article 10 monsieur le Président
rotaillot prévoit l'article 10 prévoit
l'éloignement pour les personnes
irrégulières nous levons les protections
nous faisons pareil que ce que vous
souhaitez faire mais dans deux articles
différents un pour répondre au régime de
l'expulsion et un pour répondre au
régime d'éloignement
donc non mais je je c'est pour ça que je
vous propose monsieur le Président r
d'abord d'améliorer très largement
l'expulsion pour pour pour les personnes
régulières parce qu'on a déjà ce premier
problème nous aurons un débat sur
l'article 10 c'estailles objectivement
nous pourrions tout à fait sousamender
lors de l'article 10 en s'inspirant des
propos écrits de Monsieur KCI l'article
10 mais si nous confondons les deux exps
si nous mettons une ame pour les
personnes irrégulières en levant toutes
les protections personnes irrégulières
je croit qu'il y a un fait qui CELI que
observe le Conseil d'État et qui obser
attendu du Conseil d'État il est sur le
texte que j'ai déposé donc je partage
votre avis il y a un fait voilà qui est
qu' a deux régimes différents et qui se
rapprochent donc c'est un non non pas
parce que j'ai pas envie de faire
adopteramendement de Monsieur KCI c'est
un N parce que nous allons confondre les
deux régimes le Conseil d'État nous a
prévenu alors qu'il a été je crois très
à l'écoute de la demande du gouvernement
sur la levée des protections en général
il aurait pu très bien considérer qu'il
y avait un principe de fraternité ou je
ne sais quoi il ne l'a pas fait il ne
l'a pas fait le Conseil d'État il nous a
suivi sur l'article 9 sur l'article 10
sur l'article 13 donc voilà j'attire
juste attention que à force de de de
pouvoir d'être très très dur et c'est ce
qu' voulu le gouvernement puisque c'est
la disposition que nous avons proposé
faut savoir s'arrêter au bord dont on
pense que le Conseil d'État nous nous
indique ces principes du conseil de
l'État et de pouvoir avoir une une
validation du Conseil constitutionnel
moi je vais vous dire Monsieur le
Président rotalo c'est une discussion
intéressante évidemment très
intéressante mais mais c'est c'est ça la
limite sans doute du moment où la loi
ordinaire s'arrête sur le bloc de
constitutionnalité donc le débat que
vous avez ici que nous avons ici n'est
pas n'est pas noin n'est pas médiocre il
est juste pas dans le à mon avis dans le
bon texte de loi il est dans le texte de
loi constitutionnelle il est pas dans le
texte de loi
ordinaire merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le
Président bien compris les enjeux qui
sont extrêmement importants sur plan
juridique je vous demande s'il vous
plaît une suspension de séance de 3
minutes pour la suspension de séance est
accordée nous reprenons les travaux dans
3 minutes
suspendu
la séance est reprise monsieur le
président de la commission des lois vous
avez demander la
parole madame le Président
euh nous avons demandé pour la clarté
des débats pour que tout le monde soit
au courant nous allons la Commission va
sous-amender l'amendement de Monsieur
carucci la rédaction est en cours elle
sera je pense Mame la présidente
distribuée dans dans peu de dans peu de
secondes et de peu de minutes donc voilà
la première mesure à faire il faut donc
nous sous-amendons votre amendement
monsieur carouci ensuite monsieur
rotillot dira ce qu'il fait sur son
amendement merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président
rotillot si j'ai toutes les garanties
que les amendements euh qui vont
restreindre drastiquement les
protections aussi bien absolu que
relativ aux mesures d'expulsion sont
présentes je retire mon amendement bien
merci monsieur le Président nous
arrivons à la discussion de 9
amendements discussion commune le
premier celui de la commission le 630
présenté par Monsieur Madame la
Présidente conform à l'engagement avec
votre prédécesseur il est soutenu
défendu il est soutenu et défendu
monsieur non non discussion commune
pardon je on va tous les présenter le 79
rectifié madame de La Gonterie comment
elle s'appelle allez-y chers collègues
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre alors pardon de de
rompre l'ambiance dans laquelle nous
vivons depuis petite demi-heure
maintenant je sais pas pourquoi il y a
un écho tiens pousse peut-être ton
portable je pense c'est toi qui fait de
l'écho
euh nous avons déposé cet amendement
parce que le sujet tel qu'il est posé il
est grave et sérieux grave et sérieux
sur le plan des principes graves et
sérieux sur le plan de leur mise en
œuvre
euh le projet de loi prévoit d'abolir
les protections légales contre
l'exulsion non plus en fonction de la
peine prononcée mais de la peine
encourue et la levée des protections
elle doit évidemment pouvoir être
possible mais elle doit respecter la
proportionnalité bien sûr et le respect
du principe d'individualisation des
peines et c'est exactement cela qui est
en train d'être mis à bas il y a une
disproportion entre le motif sur lequel
reposerait l'expulsion et les étrangers
concernés je vous donne un exemple hein
un étranger établi en France depuis au
moins 10 ans pour être pourrait être
pardon expulsé pour des délit de faible
gravité un vol à la tire dans le métro
pourrait demain permettre une expulsion
aujourd'hui dans le code pénal c'est un
vol aggravé au sens de l'article 3114
puni de 5 an
d'emprisonnement c'est ça la traduction
concrète et opérationnelle de ce qui est
en train d'être prononcer et évidemment
pardon de remettre quelques principes
qui font en effet l'État de droit cette
mesure elle contredit le principe
d'individualisation des peines qui
garantit que le prononcé de la peine est
en fonction de la gravité de
l'infraction et de la personnalité de
son auteur je vous rappelle pas
l'article 8 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen et évidemment
le l'ensemble des décisions du du
Conseil constitutionnel et donc c'est
pour ça que nous on propose évidemment
que la levée de la protection ne soit
possible qu'au regard de la peine
effectivement prononcée en l'espèce une
peine d'emprisonnement ferme au moins
égale à 10 ans pour les étrangers
protégés au titre de l'article
l631 3 merci à vous madame Brossel
monsieur benaroche pour rappel au
règlement madame la Présidente au
règlement juste pour signaler malgré
tout que bien avant l'interruption de
séance euh j'avais demandé la parole sur
les amendements de Monsieur rotaillot et
sur le sur le la discussion qui avait
lieu entre monsieur Darmanin les
rapporteurs et Monsieur rotillot
j'espérais
l'avir avant de passer à l'étude de des
des amendements suivants je l'ai pas eu
donc je voulais simplement m'en étonner
puisque je comprends bien effectivement
que là il y a une discussion comment
dire en en direct live parce que les
négociations d'hier qui ont amené à
voter certains articles sont peut-être
pas totalement terminés mais on se
retrouve un peu dans la même cas de
configuration qu'au moment de l'article
sur les ame c'est-à-dire que je je je
note je déplore que pour la première
fois depuis 3 ans que je me trouve dans
cette assemblée et à la commission des
lois un certain nombre de chance de sans
plus faites en fonction effectivement
des avis réellement des commissaires des
lois et des avis à la fois juridiques et
bien entendu politiques mais son fait en
en fonction d'une négociation qui a lieu
maintenant aujourd'hui j'aurais presque
envie de dire à ciel ouvert même si nous
sommes sous une coupol et que bien
entendu tout le reste de l'assemblée que
nous sommes assiste à cela aux
spectateurs S que il y a eu aucune
possibilité d'intervenir puisque même ma
demande de parole sur cet article je
n'ai pas pu la faire voilà merci
monsieur benaroche nous avions bien
repéré que vous nous aviez demandé fait
le une demande de parole mais
l'amendement de monsieur retaillot est
en retirer il n'y a pas d'explication de
vote et donc pas de possibilité de vous
donner la parole en revanche je vous la
donne sur la défense de l'amendement
316 je m'excuse c'était pas une
explication de vote je je demandais la
parole bien avant l'interruption et bien
avant le vé par Monsieur R je peux vous
donner la parole que s'il y a
explication de vote et que si
l'amendement est maintenu comme
l'amendement n'est pas maintenu je donne
pas la parole bcte vous l'avez
maintenant sur l'amendement
316 merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement de repli par rapport à celui
que nous avons présenté tout à l'heure
vise à lever les dérogations à la
protection des parents d'enfants
français et des personnes mariées contre
l'expulsion le maintien des liens avec
les parents doit être préservé pour
chaque enfant même lorsque ces parents
sont condamnés pénalement ou incarcérés
cela doit s'appliquer sans
discrimination pour les mineurs que
leurs parents soient français ou
étranger en situation régulière ou
irrégulière le Comité des droits de
l'enfant soulligne que la rupture de
l'unité familiale par l'expulsion de
l'un des parents ou des deux parents en
raison d'une infraction au loi relative
à l'immigration liée à l'entrée ou au
séjour est disproportionné en ce que le
sacrifice inérant à la restriction de la
vie de famille et au conséquence sur la
vie et le développement de l'enfant
n'est pas compensé par les avantages
obtenus par le fait de forcer le parent
à quitter le territoire au motif d'une
infraction à la législation relative le
principe figurant dans de nombreuses
dispositions déjà en vigueur selon
lequel pour les étrangers s'ajoute à la
sanction pénale une sanction spécifique
liée à leur qualité d'étranger qualifié
de double peine est aujourdhui associé à
des garanties spécifiques pour les
personnes ayant des liens familiaux en
France or le projet de loi érode un peu
plus ses garanties augmentant le risque
de rupture dans l'unité familiale et les
conséquences pour le maintien des liens
familiaux et le développement de
l'enfant ces dispositions risquent de
creuser la différence de traitement
entre les enfants de parents étrangers
ayant menacé gravement l'ordre public et
ceux dont les parents n'ont pas comis
d'infraction le risque ici est de
restraindre de façon disproportionner la
réalisation des droits des étrangers
parant d'enfants français et de
compromettre les droits de leurs enfants
mineur parce que ces dispositions sont
contraires à l'article 8 de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme concernant le droit de mener une
vie familiale normale notre groupe
demande l'exclusion des dérogations à la
protection des parents d'enfants
français et les personnes mariées contre
l'expulsion cette amendement est inspiré
des travaux de l'UNICEF merci Monsieur
benaroche Madame Monsieur Madame la
rapporteur pour l'amendement 631 de la
commission il est considéré comme
présenté il a déjà été présenté déjà
défendu l'amendement 561 madame
romagie non monsieur ah oui par je suis
là merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
connaissons certainement la fin de cette
histoire mais je tenais quand même à
défendre cet amendement puisque je
rejoins il rejoint en tout cas beaucoup
le l'amendement de Monsieur reillot cet
amendement que je propose vise à
renforcer l'arsenal juridique et à
outiller la et l'administration pour
protéger les citoyens de notre pays il
répond à une demande de fermeté
vis-à-vis des criminels demande
largement partagé par les Français
d'autant plus au regard des derniers
événements dramatiques qu'ont connu
notre pays deux objectif à cet
amendement qui je le précise tout de
suite n'est pas une mesure d'ordre
général il n'est ni exclusif ni fermé le
premier objectif donc est d'élargir la
peine automatique je sais que c'est un
mot qui ange d'interdiction de de de
territoire français prévu en matière de
terrorisme à l'ensemble des crimes ou
délits punis de 5 ans ou plus
d'emprisonnement sauf décision motivée
du juge qui pourra prendre en compte les
circonstances de l'infraction ou la
personnalité de son auteur et le
deuxième objectif est de supprimer
l'automaticité cette fois des
protections qui dans le droit actuel
empêche au tribunal et ce de manière
inéluctable de prononcer des
ITF ajoute y compris à l'encontre des
terroristes le juge aura toujours la
possibilité de ne pas appliquer le qtf
en fonction de circonstances motivées
l'idée vous l'aurez compris est
d'inverser la vapeur mais nous en
parlons depuis suffisamment de temps
maintenant que l'expulsion des criminels
étrangers deviennent la règle et que le
juge a la faculté d'y déroger et non
l'inverse je vous remercie merci Madame
romaniie le 134 défendu par Monsieur
sourc
oui c'est à VOUS excusez-moi madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre Monsieur
Madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise inscrire dans le
marbreon de la loi le principe d'une
interdiction du territoire définitive à
l'encontre de tout étranger coupable
d'un crime mais également la
prononciation d'une interdiction de
territoire d'une durée de 10 ans à
l'encontre de tout étranger coupable
d'un délit paylé d'une peine
d'emprisonnement d'une durée supérieure
ou égale à 2 ans cet amendement vise
donc à clarifier la peine d'interdiction
du territoire français les étrangers qui
ont gravement porté atteinte aux règles
qui régissent la société française
nonont pas leur place sur le territoire
national l'interdiction définitive du
territoire français doit donc
s'appliquer à titre permanent à l'égard
de ceux qui ont commis un crime il est
incompréhensible pour nos compatriotes
qu'un étranger ayant commis un crime est
une seule chance de rester sur le
territoire national à l'issue de sa
condamnation un étranger doit avoir un
comportement irréprochable lorsqu'il est
légalement accueilli par le peuple
français sur le sol national ainsi nous
proposons qu'une pa d'interdiction de 10
ans du territoire soit prononcée pour
tout tout étranger coupable d'une d'un
d'un délit
euh puni d'une peine d'emprisonnement
d'une durée supérie égale à 2 ans ou
d'un délit pour lequel la peine
d'interdiction du territoire français
est prévu par la loi de plus les propres
services du ministère de l'Intérieur
nous apprennent que 93 % des mises en
cause pour vol 72 % des auteurs de vol
et violence 32 % des condamnés pour cû
et blessurees sont le fait d'étranger
ces personnes une fois condamné n'ont
rien à faire sur notre sol chers
collègues nous vous appelons au bon sens
et à la fermeté l'étranger qui en frein
nos loi n'a plus sa place à nos côtés et
nous législateurs devons veiller à
protéger avant tout nos compatriotes en
expulsant ce qu'il mérite merci merci
amendement 180 présenté par Monsieur
chayou la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
je voudrais de nouveau comme a pu le
faire ma collègue la sénatrice colombe
Brossel insister sur cet aspect qui nous
semble fondamental du principe de
l'individualisation des peines puisque
cet article 9 prévoit qu'il n'y aura
plus d'obligation de motivation de
décision dans deux cas de figures très
particulier et très honnêtement cela
nous interpelle profondément y compris
au regard des principes fondamentaux du
droit et de l'État de droit pourquoi
craint-on qu'il n'y ait plus de
nécessité de motiver certaines décisions
alors qu'encore une fois c'est un
principe qui nous semble assez
fondamental c'est une mesure très lourde
celle qui consiste à interdire du
territoire français donc il serait tout
à fait légitime de pouvoir
considérer que nous devons toujours et
que le juge doit
toujours motiver et justifier cette
décision à la fois au regard la gravité
de l'infraction mais aussi au regard de
la situation personnelle et familiale de
de l'étranger d'ailleurs n permettons
d'attirer votre attention sur l'avis du
Conseil d'État qui lui-même recommande
de ne pas retenir cette disposition
puisque le Conseil d'État a estimé que
cette dérogation introduit une
incertitude quand on maintient de
l'obligation générale de motivation qui
s'impose en matière correctionnel en
application de l'article l131 1321 du
code pénal et notamment qui précise que
c'est incompatible avec les exigences
attachées au contrôle de
proportionnaliser de proportionnalité
réalisé au titre de l'article 8 de la
CEDH qui implique que l'ensemble des
éléments utiles à ce contrôle ressorte
des motifs du jugement c'est la raisons
pour lesquel à travers cet amendement il
nous semble important de revenir aux
principes fondamentaux de droit et de
l'État de droit merci chers collègu
amendement 103 rectifié madame D'cos
merci madame la Présidente mon collègue
Louis Le Vogel a souhaité que je défende
son amendement considérant qu'il n'est
pas tolérable que des étrangers auteur
de graves infractions puissent se
maintenir impunément sur le territoire
national la Commission a choisi à
travers cet article de clarifier les
critères de levée de de la protection
systématisée par cette levée à
l'encontre des auteurs de violence
intrafamilial et généraliser la
possibilité pour le juge de prononcer
des ITF l'article 9 prévoit ainsi de
faciliter l'expulsion des étrangers qui
constituent une menace pour l'ordre
public ou pour nos concitoyens seront
notamment concernés ceux qui aont commis
des infractions graves ou répété pour
autant considérant que l'alinéa 10 de
cet article emploie le terme de
réitération d'infraction tandis que
l'alinéa 24 vise la récidive il est donc
préférable de s'entenir à la notion de
réitération le simple fait d'être
l'objet de plusieurs condamnations
définitives justifie l'expulsion de
l'étranger concerné je vous remercie
merci Madame Darcos le 52 rectifi madame
Boyer
merci madame la Présidente
euh il s'agit
d'un pour pour les raisons pardon
excusez-moi évoqué par le Président
rotaillot je vais retirer cet amendement
mais parce que je souhaitais voir le
prononcer d'une interdiction du
territoire français à l'encontre de tout
étranger quiuse de menace ou de violence
ou qui commet tout autre acte
d'intimidation à l'égard d'une personne
participant à l'exécution d'une mission
de service public devienent la règle
mais les amendements que vous proposez
ben je pense arriveront à satisfaire
cette demande merci Madame Boyer avis de
la commission si vous pouvez me résumer
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements volontiers je ne reviens pas
sur l'amendement sur le l'avis favorable
sur notre propre amendement
630 avis défavorable sur le 179 présenté
par Madame la griie et ses collègues 316
monsieur de La Roche et Monsieur
benaroche excusez-moi et ses collègues
631 favorable c'est bien sûr notre
amendement
561 madame
Romanie vous avez suivi les débat vous
avez compris que vous avez obtenu
satisfaction et sur la question d'aras
vous avez une double réponse favorable
l'intéressé serait éloigné expulsé
pardon en résultant d'une part des
violences intrafamiliales que nous
étendons aux ascendants et sa situation
irrégulière est-ce que vous pourriez
retirer dans dans ces conditions votre
amendement je vous remercie je retire
mon amendement le 134 monsieur zurex
c'est défavorable sauf retrait le 180 de
Madame de La Gonterie également
défavorable et le 100 le 103 de Monsieur
Vogel réitération récidive
favorable très bien avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre c'est un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble des
amendements le 631 de Madame Jourda les
violences intrafamiliales sur ascendant
avec un peut-être un petit risque
constitutionnel mais on va on va
regarder lors de la navette mais je
pense qu'on peut prendre ce
risque en revanche c'est un avis donc
défav pour les autres soit parce qu'ils
veulent amoindrir ou supprimer des
dispositions d'article 9 soit parce
qu'ils ne sont pas constitutionnels à
notre lecture j'en suis désolé favorable
sauf le 631 et y compris le 630 le
premier de la commission très bien je
vais donc mettre au voix ces amendements
donc l'amendement 630 avec un avis
favorable de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
l'adoption de cet
amendement qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est donc adopté et il fait tomber le
suivant le 179 je mets au voix le 316
rectifié avec un double avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'amendement 631
de la commission avec un double avis
favorable qui est pour cet
amendement qui s'abstient qui est contre
il est adopté amendement 561 tombe
l'amendement 134 tombe également le 180
tombe également le 103 un avis favorable
de la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour son
adoption
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté très bien nous passons ensuite à
trois amendements en discussion commune
le 610 présenté par le gouvernement
défendu le 583 présenté par Madame
ashliman merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre cet amendement vise
à lever les protections contre
l'expulsion d'un étranger condamné
définitivement à une peine de prison
supérieure à 5 ans lorsque les faits à
l'origine de cette expulsion ont été
commis contre les titula de certaines
fonctions notamment les agents publics
les personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique les policiers les pompiers les
enseignants et l'assassinat récent du
professeur d'aras en est un exemple
flagrant les soignants je disais mais
aussi les avocats les magistrats
j'ajoute que cette levée de protection
concerne autant les protections
relatives que les protections absolues
on ne peut en effet tolérer qu'un
étranger qui s'attaque à ceux qui
œuvrent quotidiennement pour l'intérêt
général pour notre sécurité pour notre
État de droit pour l'éducation de nos
enfants ne puissent être expulsés du
territoire français notre République
doit faire preuve de la plus grande
fermeté vis-à-vis de ceux qui
s'attaquent à elle qui SAP les
fondements de notre État de droit de nos
libertés et de la démocratie je vous
merci merci Madame hasiman président
kucci
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je veux pas être très long
parce que on en a tellement parlé de cet
amendement avant même que je ne le
présente
que il en devient quelque chose d'assez
banal conformément monsieur le ministre
à ce que vous avez fait comme remarque
sur le positionnement du Conseil d'État
ce que pourrait être le positionnement
du Conseil constitutionnel et après
après donc discussion avec le président
de la commission des lois le
349 est modifié c'est-à-dire que puisque
tout le monde l'a reçu le rectifier si
je puis dire comment non bah si on m'a
dit il est
rectifi 349 fre F et vous allez nous
expliquer la rectification monsieur le
Président
carouci de
d'impression allez-y monsieur carucci
trile je vous rassure que ce soit après
l'alinéa 6 si vous avez l'amendement
sous les yeux ou après l'alinéa 10 nous
rajoutons dans les deux cas la même
formulation euh vous avez jusqu'au bout
qui est en situation irrégulière au
regard du séjour et là ça se modifie si
cette irrégularité résulte d'une
décision de retrait du titre de séjour
en application de l'article 432 d'un
refus de renouvellement sur le fondement
de l'article 412 ou du 1 de l'article
432 3 dans les deux cas que ce soit sur
le 6 ou le 10 c'est la même
modification ce qui rend cet cet
amendement donc apparemment du moins je
l'espère conforme aux règles établi
conforme à ce que souhaite impose le
Conseil d'État pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème devant le Conseil
constitutionnel si la Commission en est
d'accord et le gouvernement aussi j'en
serai avis pour que le Conseil
constitutionnel soit dans un état
d'extase devant mon amendement merci
chers collègues en attendant l'extase du
Conseil d'État on va demander l'avis de
la commission sur ces trois amendements
oui madame le présidente comme vous
l'avez compris nous sommes favorable à
l'amendement
delichman
excusez-moilman excusez-moi madame je je
ça je me permettrai
pas favorable également à à l'amendement
présenté par Monsieur kouci et ses
collègues en tenant compte la réserve du
Conseil d'État et à travers
cela le cet amendement se
trouve fait l'objet de la même rédaction
que celle du gouvernement ce qui nous
permet de vous donner trois amendements
de favorablees et comme madame le
Président chacun fait un grand effort
pour vraiment respecter les règles
constitutionnelle sans me permettre
d'empiéter sur vos prérogatives de
présidence de la séance je voudrais
simplement avoir la certitude au moment
où on passe au vote que tout le monde a
bien eu l'amendement que tout le monde a
eu le temps de lire pour que nous ne
heurtions pas au moment du contrôle du
Conseil constitutionnel sur un débat
quant à la connaissance de la loi la
clarté je je permets excusez-moi sans je
je ne doute pas que vous auriez prêté
attention madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le rapporteur pour laisser
chacun le temps de lire l'amendement je
vais demander l'avis du Gouvernement sur
les deux amendements de Madame hashliman
et du président
kuchci
accord madame la Présidente je vais
donner un avis favorable à son
l'amendement de Monsieur KCI qui
rectifie son amendement si jeai bien
compris en reprenant une partie du 610
du gouvernement donc je retire le mien
je retire le 610 je soutiens donc celui
de Monsieur kucci et je donne un avis
favorable à celui madame
haschiman très bien merci Monsieur le
Ministre est-ce que tout le monde a pu
prendre connaissance du rectifier terre
de Monsieur
carucci voyons pas d'opposition je vais
donc mettre au voix les deux amendements
qui restent puisque le 610 a été retiré
par le gouvernement donc je mets au voix
l'article l'amendement pardon 583
rectifié bis porté par Madame hashliman
avec deux avis favorables de du
gouvernement et de la commission qui est
pour qui est contre